you know nearly every person I know has
struggled with this for me that feeling
of I should be further ahead by now
totally dominated my early 20s I was in
constant angst and it was really painful
and in my work I've heard the same
struggle from people in their 30s and
their 40s and their 50s and 60s and 70s
Etc I believe this is a sickness that we
human beings have and if you don't get a
handle on this thing right now you will
continue to feel empty and desperate and
hopeless no matter what you do or no
matter what you achieve now the good
news is that there are only two things
that you need to do in order to heal
yourself from this sickness and it's
important to know that these are not
one-time actions my dear these are
conscious choices that you have to make
each and every single day number one I
want you to adore your detours so what
does that mean you gotta ask yourself
have you ever taken a road trip probably
so sometimes you don't get to your
destination at the time that you thought
you would because you took a little
detour maybe you decided at the last
minute you know what we want to take the
scenic route you have got to trust the
timing of your life you have to trust
that you made the best choices you could
have possibly made at the time because
guess what you made them and trust that
every experience taught you something
that you need to know right now need
motivation with relief Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from one of the best Marie forleo and my
take on her top 10 rules of success
enjoy
rule number two break bad habits I don't
think that there is any human on the
planet who at any given time doesn't
have at least one habit that really
needs to get kicked to the curb well it
turns out that there's a simple two-word
fix that can dramatically increase our
ability to resist temptation and it
gives us a better chance to make a
better choice now this is based on
Research done by Dr Vanessa Patrick
she's a professor of marketing at the
University of Houston who published her
findings on the power of self-talk in
the Journal of consumer research she
found that when participants framed a
refusal as I don't for instance I don't
eat chocolate cake or I don't eat sugar
instead of I can't they were more
successful at resisting the desire to
eat unhealthy Foods or skip the gym in
fact they found that when it came to
deciding whether to eat certain foods
saying I don't was nearly three times as
effective as saying no and about eight
times more effective than saying I can't
very interesting right I don't versus I
can't two teeny tiny words that can make
a ginormous difference and here's why
when we say I don't we are empowered
we're determined we are at Choice it's a
tough strong phrase like end of story
but when we say I can't we disempower
ourselves it sounds like we're not
allowed to do something by some outside
force you know what we make ourselves
feel deprived when we say I can and in
essence we make ourselves weak whiny
little like
I can't have a cookie now it's even
cooler though is that we can tuck this
little trick into every corner of our
Lives we can start making some clear
strong declarations like this
I don't eat skinny pop every night
I don't look at my phone during dinner
I don't unnecessarily use the marietv
set
I don't put the toilet seat down
I don't refer to everyone whose name I
don't immediately remember as
chimichanga
I don't show up to the set of marietv
nude
starting tomorrow
[Music]
I don't stay up until 3am watching bear
attack videos rubbing Fried Chicken all
over my thighs
I don't say no to new experiences
I don't shave
pretty awesome right rule number three
write down your goals Common Sense isn't
always common practice and this is why
we have to go back to the fundamentals
sometimes before we can get to those
Advanced tactics before we can get more
subtle and into more nuanced things so
the habit is this write down your goals
studies show in fact a study by Dr um uh
Halverson showed that we human beings
are literally 42 percent more likely to
achieve our goals if we simply write
them down and this isn't about magic
well there is some magic to it but in a
very literal sense it's about Focus you
know Vision one of the things that I did
I had this dream when I was writing the
book which by the way I was horrible at
writing this book I was so stressed out
I was putting so much pressure on myself
I wanted so badly to make it as good as
it could possibly be and I was driving
myself Bonkers and one of the things I
did every morning I didn't just write
down my goals for the book I had a very
specific goal which was this I wanted to
the best of my ability to set up this
book to be a number one New York Times
bestseller and you and I both know
because we have so many friends in the
industry and so many authors you can't
control that you know especially if
you're doing it completely organically
right it's one of those things you just
kind of hope for maybe it'll happen
maybe it won't but here's what I did
Vision I took that idea that simple
habit of just writing down goals and I
went further I wrote down I am a number
one New York Times bestseller 15 times
every single morning in my journal for
probably about 18 months I still have
all the journals in my drawers uh
sometimes every single morning that is
so interesting every morning and it was
using the words I am right so it was
just I am a number one New York Times
best-selling author I am a number one
New York Times best-selling author and
my intention was around this book again
completely consciously knowing first of
all that that is an arbitrary goal well
second of all there's a little bit of
ego involved but third of all I also
knew that if I could at least get on the
list or maybe get to be number one the
most important thing for me wasn't about
the title for myself it was about the
fact that that would get this book and
this message into more hands it would
give it that extra little bit of
credibility that would hopefully get
this idea out and one of the things I
wrote about in the beginning of the book
was this you know a friend of mine who
is the CEO of Shopify I ran into him in
New York while I was working on the book
and by working on the book I mean
stressing out over it and Toby uh is his
name he's like you know what are you
working on I said I'm working on this
book and he's like why are you writing a
book he's like that's a huge project
your business is going great you have so
many other things going on like why did
you say yes to this and I said Toby you
know what
if I were to get hit by a bus tomorrow
and I could only leave one thing behind
it would be this idea if I can do a good
enough job explaining this philosophy
this belief and the profound
transformation that it can spark in
every human being then I can be like
riding off on the Unicorn my Cosmic next
adventure going like all right I did it
peace
taking it back to 2010. but that was the
feeling I had so
um you know this idea of writing that
down every single morning and it was
like 5 a.m you know and sometimes I
would be so blurry-eyed and I didn't
want to do it but I did it every single
morning 15 times and when the New York
Times list came out the week after we
published a vision I like broke down in
the ugly cry like I could not even
breathe I was partially exhausted
because we were on tour and I was
traveling around and doing just you know
like a ton of stops or whatever and
partially just so
um humbled and so emotionally just like
an emotional release uh so that's the
Habit The Habit it's so simple write
down your goals if you want to
supercharge it if you want to take it to
that next level and you have a singular
goal that you're working on right now
that is more important in your heart
than anything else write it down 15
times a day we all know we have
something called the reticular
activating system that part of our brain
that helps us sift and sort what's
important and what's not and on the most
basic level writing your top goal down
every single day 15 times will give you
the focus that you need every morning to
not get distracted by shiny objects and
to do everything in your power to
activate that goal and to help bring it
to life rule number four don't compare
yourself to others back in college I had
some nasty nights doing shots of this
awful cinnamon flavored liqueur called
Goldschlager it's pretty much disgusting
now when you compare your path with
someone else's you're basically drinking
compare schlager which is like a hundred
times worse for you than Goldschlager
and I gotta say that is not easy to do
now you know that you've been doing
shots of compare jogger when you're left
with a major comparison hangover which
is what you're experiencing right now
now comparison is where all of this I
should be further ahead by now BS stuff
comes from and I guarantee you if you
stop doing shots of compare schlager two
of very large extent you're going to
stop feeling all this angst and anxiety
and hopelessness they say comparison is
the thief of Joy I say it's the
Hamburglar of happiness it will not rest
until it takes all of your self-esteem
makes off with it into the night and
leaves you doing the ugly cry in the
corner so you might be asking yourself
well how do you stop comparing it's
pretty simple you have got to put
blinders on because constantly looking
to the right or to the left is actually
what's slowing you down and you need to
focus on your own game so if you really
want to do a comparison cleanse try this
do a total social media detox and stop
following or looking at people who you
tend to compare yourself to don't pick
up magazines or watch TV shows that
portray some unrealistic ideal of
perfection do not go actively searching
for things that you know are going to
leave you feeling upset now I know that
this takes discipline and it takes
constant vigilance but I gotta tell you
commit to this and I promise you will
feel better than you've ever felt before
and you're going to have more time and
energy to make your dreams come to life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five aim to be great
sometimes the only way to create what
you really want means walking away from
the sure thing you already have now
before we dive into this I want to share
a little line from Jim Collins the
author of the classic book good to Great
Jim says good is the enemy of great and
is why so many things don't become great
we don't have really great schools
because we have good schools we don't
have great companies because we have so
many good ones and when we look back
over our life and see if it's a great
one we don't see many because it's just
so easy to settle for a good one now if
we unpack this a bit we'll see that
there's two main factors that keep us
trapped in good land
[Music]
number one is Comfort whether it's a
certain amount of money that you're used
to making or a warm body next to you
when you're watching Game of Thrones
sometimes it's hard to walk away from
the sure thing you already have because
you're not sure if you're going to find
something out there that's better to
fill the void Marie don't leave Goodland
it's good enough here number two is what
I call Ope other people's expectations
tough to ignore but fun to dance to
[Music]
not this
the reason ope is so hard to break free
from is because we don't want to
disappoint people we don't let them down
and of course we don't want to rock the
boat but if you want to shift anything
from good to Great you've got to be
willing to shake some shiz up which is
exactly what I had to do when I walked
away from over a million dollars in
Revenue yes people were disappointed and
yes people thought I was crazy pants
little side note if people think you're
crazy pants you are probably wearing the
right pants
that's deep
so here's the story back in the day I
had two awesome programs one was an
annual conference that we held at Donna
Karen's Urban Zen Center and the other
was a year-long mentorship and travel
program called Adventure Mastermind both
of these programs sold out each year
with a waiting list they were fun they
were life-changing and they were like
nothing else on the market and they were
both really profitable however I was
having this inner tug inside that it was
time for me to clear the decks and work
on new projects that would allow me to
change as many lives as possible now I'm
not going to front this was not easy to
do a million dollars is a lot of
freaking money and B I love what I do
and it was hard for me to disappoint so
many people who wanted to take those
programs but then wouldn't have a chance
to so I couldn't deny what I knew to be
true which was that it was time for me
to walk away and that's what I did now
check this out about a week or so after
I decided to take those programs off the
market I got a call from Oprah's folks
to be on Super Soul Sunday coincidence
maybe or maybe it was meant to be
because you can't have really amazing
stuff show up in your life if you don't
have room for it so let's wrap this up
with a few things to keep in mind first
of all we always say that if it ain't
broke don't fix it but if it ain't broke
it doesn't mean that you should keep it
furthermore things don't have to be
crashing and burning around you in order
for you to walk away you can leave in a
high note things don't have to get
dramatic and they don't have to get
crazy
second as Jim Collins said good is the
enemy of great complacency can be a
curse so watch out for it rule number
six embrace your ambition according to
Frankel he believed that one component
of well-being is based on a certain
degree of tension between what one has
already accomplished and what one has
yet to achieve so in other words who you
are today and who you hope to become
tomorrow so if you're worried or ever
have those thoughts that somehow you're
a failure because you haven't achieved
all of your dreams quite yet listen to
me when I say this you are not a failure
that tension is a really good thing so
Embrace that drive that you have embrace
your ambition and the gap between where
you are and who you are today and where
you want to go and who you want to
become over the next year and 10 years
and so on so when it comes to making
meaning in our lives Frankel shares
three simple Avenues the First Avenue is
creating work or doing a deed in other
words having a project that you're
working on that requires your skills and
abilities you know one of the most
powerful stories in the book for me was
when Frankl arrived at Auschwitz and he
had the manuscript for a book that he
was working on and he had it in his coat
pocket and when he arrived They
confiscated it from him just like
everything else and he was heartbroken
but what he did throughout his time
there is he started looking for these
little scraps of paper and he was
collecting them so he could start
recreating his manuscript and that
really helped keep him focused and there
was this other thing that he shared that
I really related to you know while I
have a stepson and I have a fur baby I
don't have any biological children and
he was talking about this book being his
mental child and having the ability to
focus on that mental child and how
important it was for him to nurture it
and bring it to life and put that
manuscript back together was really a
key in helping him survive that
experience the Second Avenue by
experiencing something or someone so in
other words experiencing beauty or truth
or goodness or love whether that's
through nature or by loving someone else
you know Frankel shares these moments
throughout the book for example when he
was being transferred from Auschwitz to
a Bavarian Camp by train how he and
everyone was in this crowded train and
they were crowding around this tiny
barred window just to catch a glimpse of
the Mountainside and the beautiful
sunset and in Frankel's own words he
said we were Carried Away by Nature's
Beauty which we had missed for so long
or the other thing that really stood out
to me in the book was how much Victor
connected with his wife through his
thoughts and his imagination and how
much his love for her kept him fueled
and really kept him going and there was
one passage that I want to read which
sums it up he wrote
then I grasp the meaning of The Greatest
Secret that human poetry and human
thought and belief have to impart the
salvation of man is through love and in
love I understood how a man who has
nothing left in this world still may
know Bliss be it only for a brief moment
in the contemplation of his beloved
the third and final Avenue is the
attitude that we take towards
unavoidable suffering in other words our
human capacity to transform personal
tragedy into Triumph this is probably
the biggest message that I took away
from the book you know Victor discovered
through surviving what is arguably one
of the most horrific experiences you
could ever imagine that he was able to
find meaning and growth and a deeper
sense of who he was as a human being as
a result and there was one really
incredible Insight that he shared which
was this in some way suffering ceases to
be suffering at the moment it finds a
meaning we hear stories about this every
day right I mean where people face
unimaginable challenges that could break
them but somehow they wind up growing
stronger and more resilient and even
more fulfilled as a result so while
there are many different schools of
thought around meaning and fulfillment I
found Victor Frankel's three part art
framework really speaks to my heart one
of the reasons that I love it so much is
because I think many of us can get lost
looking outside of ourselves for how to
create a meaningful life and what Victor
Frankel so beautifully teaches us is
that each of those three Avenues is
completely within our control
so whether you're watching this over the
holidays or any time of year and you're
feeling a little down or you're feeling
a little empty I want you to remember
this
rather than searching for life's meaning
remember that you always have the power
to create it rule number seven engage in
the moment here's the reality check that
hit me like a ton of bricks all of the
joy and excitement and fun that we want
in life never comes from external
circumstances it always comes from the
energy and the attention and the
Consciousness that we bring into each
and every moment so Lori I talked about
this a lot and if you really want to
solve this problem I need you to go read
page 10 in my book make every man want
you it's all about making is-ness your
business so what does that mean making
isness your business means that you show
up in each moment and you do this Moment
Like You friggin mean it that means you
bring your A game that means you bring
your full enthusiasm your attention your
love to whatever you're doing wherever
you are and whoever you're with why
because all pain and frustration and
annoyance in our life comes from
resisting the moment it comes from
saying this moment isn't how it should
be but guess what the moment already is
you only have two choices in life you
can either resist it and be freaking
miserable or you can engage with the
moment and have a damn good time in fact
make it an engagement party you guys
I'm engaged
[Applause]
with the moment what
okay that's right you gotta love the
moment put a ring on it because the
truth is you can feel Fully Alive in any
situation or you can feel like total
crap in any situation it's not the
circumstances it's actually what you
bring to them once I really got this I
was so much happier I was performing in
my jobs better and ironically everything
that I wanted to create in my future
started happening a lot faster well
number eight learn to rest last year I
had a life changing carb craving
specifically I wanted a croissant and my
first thought I should walk around the
corner to that cute little French bakery
that I've been always meaning to try
it's one of those places that you
probably have in your neighborhood where
you walk by a million times but for
whatever reason you never go in so I
walk over and as I'm getting up to the
door I notice this little white piece of
paper on the glass door and it says this
closed due to vacation now typically
when I go to a store and it's closed I'm
usually like
but this time I was actually like OMG
clothes due to Vacation it's a
revelation this is apartheid
there was no disappointment in fact it
was super inspiring to me that someone
could close down their entire business
for an extended period of time just for
vacation so nobody died they weren't
going out of business it wasn't
renovation nope they just wanted to take
time off so I got so excited by this
idea that I forgot I even wanted a
croissant I've ran home called up my
team and I told them we are closing down
at the end of the year for two whole
weeks and we did it then and guess what
we're doing again right now we're
closing down for the next two weeks now
you gotta get this was a pretty big move
for me doing stuff non-stop is pretty
much in my DNA I mean I've been working
consistently since I was 10 years old
yes I've taken vacations but this idea
of completely closing down your entire
company for an extended period of time
that's pretty radical at least for me I
mean I know they do that kind of stuff
in Europe but I'd never really seen it
done here and in this digital age and
since I run a digital company I feel
like there's this ever growing pressure
to always be on and always be responding
and always be engaging and always be
creating something new but the truth is
from my point of view this always on
always pushing always going it's really
a sickness and over time it can destroy
you it can destroy your health and your
creativity and your relationships and
everything and I mean when it comes to
your team it can burn them out and take
them completely out and the more
experience I have in this world the more
I see that personally my soul craves
down time it craves play time it craves
time completely just off the grid now if
you're anything like me and you're super
passionate about what you do even just
the thought of taking significant time
off can feel scary I mean after all
let's say you take yourself off the grid
and all of a sudden everybody forgets
about you or you miss out on some huge
opportunity or goodness gracious your
competitors get ahead
but here's what I learned when we shut
our whole company down for two weeks
last year it was the best thing we've
ever done everybody including myself
came back so refreshed and rejuvenated
and the entire team came back with new
ideas to take the company to the next
level
and this really handsome Sombrero which
we are totally making a product around I
mean you know create a sombrero and a
pinata you love
I'm telling you all of this because I
want you to remember two important
things first up great things happen when
you unplug from technology and you plug
into your real life now as much as I
love technology and I really do love it
I have learned it is vital to take time
to just let yourself be because if
you're constantly listening to the noise
of the world it's impossible to hear The
Whispers of your soul
what's that
my soul just told me that's a tweetable
now if you're thinking to yourself This
sounds great Marie but I can't take two
weeks off right now or I can't take a
whole week off that's completely fine
but ask yourself can you take 48 hours
off or maybe just one day and number two
the whole point of this episode is this
you get to write the rules in your
business in your life question
everything that you think you have to do
really challenge those assumptions do
you have to be on Twitter especially if
you don't like it do you have to work on
Mondays do you even have to wear
underwear
do you have to wear pants
that's it jams Olay
but seriously do not undercut your
ability to craft a business and a life
that you truly love rule number nine
create your definition of success your
work does not equal your worth
entrepreneurs are not better than
non-entrepreneurs and working on Wall
Street isn't better than working as a
waitress there's no such thing as only
in anything our true worth doesn't come
from the work we do it comes from who we
are as human beings now I know sometimes
that's easier said than done but if you
want to be in charge of your happiness
you need to remember that number two is
begin with the end in mind so you said
that you were feeling aimless and this
writing exercise good for a creative
writer is really going to help you
figure out where to set your sites so
it's based on Stephen covey's idea begin
with the end in mind and when I say end
I actually mean the end of your life so
imagine it's years from from now it's
your last day on Earth and you're
thinking back on the journey what kind
of memories do you want to have what
kind of Adventures will you have taken
are there certain places you went
friends you made and things you did with
them so don't just think about this
actually write it down I promise you're
gonna uncover some pretty awesome ideas
that might just be worth aiming for
number three flesh out the details so
you said that you want to feel fulfilled
and accomplished well what exactly does
that mean to you I'd love you to get
specific does that mean that you write
every day does it mean that you publish
a novel would you feel accomplished if
you just got up and put on some
underwear I certainly do I want you to
get clear and specific and make sure
that you include some things that you
can do on a daily basis so every day you
get to feel fulfilled and accomplished
annual number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is stay
motivated how do I stay motivated
especially after things have been really
difficult and we're kind of still in
this coveted stage so I want to talk
through some things that are both
important to me but as a coach I want to
give you specific advice from what I
picked up from your question and your
Vibe so first thing is self-care first
it has been a really difficult time and
it has been a really difficult year and
that stress can take a toll so one of
the keys for me to stay consistently
motivated is to make sure that I'm doing
the simple things that make the biggest
difference in terms of my energy my
health and my cognitive prowess what
does that mean meditation is a must for
me every single day we've talked about
this in the past we even have an episode
about my personal practice and we have a
free little download if you want to take
advantage of that we'll put it both in
the video and we'll put it in the
description below exercise I've talked
about this so many times in the show
because it is one of my favorite ways to
make sure that I stay energized it's one
of the things that I do to make sure
that my brain is operating at top
capacity and it's just really fun but
there's another element that I want to
mention now I'm not a doctor and I don't
play one on the internet however I try
and take really good care of my health
and one of the things that I've noticed
and that I specifically went through
recently was just understanding and
feeling like wow my energy isn't where
it normally is and you might remember
that late last year I had a pretty major
surgery so there was a lot of recovery
with that too my point is this sometimes
we get into a specific stage of life
where things that we're eating things
that we're drinking just ways that we're
living actually pull our energy down
make us more lethargic and it makes it
harder for our brain to feel energized
to be able to focus and concentrate so
um this is a book by my friend Mark
Hyman it's called the Pagan diet I'm
also reading another book by him that's
called the ultramine solution I would
highly recommend that you check these
out if you have any suspicion that you
know what maybe the things I'm putting
in my body could be creating a little
bit of stress in my gut or making me not
feel so good and I will tell you it has
made a tremendous difference in a short
amount of time in terms of my self-care
my energy my ability to focus and
concentrate and have really high energy
levels which speaks into motivation and
getting unstuck and getting things done
number two and this one is the one I
really wanted to say to you specifically
Lori so ambiguity is the enemy of
execution you talked about being a
therapist you talked about getting your
coaching certification so here's the
deal my love I need you to decide what
is the one single project that you want
to work on at this particular stage and
season of your life whether it's for a
month or the next quarter or the next
six months whatever the time frame is
and decide what that one thing is so we
can get you moving on it anytime people
come to me and say I don't know I just
have so many things I might want to do I
know that they haven't decided the one
thing that's most important right now
and they have no plan to execute on it
so since you mentioned that you have
this fantastic little book called
Everything Is figureoutable I want to
encourage you to go back to chapter six
which is Define your dream because not
only do you need to Define specifically
what you want to work on at this
particular time you also need to have a
stack of emotionally compelling reasons
why that particular project is so
important to you so it has to be
important to your heart it should be
important to your mission it should be
important to your bank account there
should be all kinds of reasons why this
particular project this Milestone or
this goal has to be reached and we need
that to be very concrete and specific so
remember ambiguity is the enemy of
execution my friend so that is step two
and now for step three I highly
recommend this most of the time people
are just going like this I don't know
what I should do I don't know what I
should focus on because they don't have
a deadline y'all people we need
deadlines they are awesome I know
sometimes it can create a little
pressure and stress but pressure and
stress in small amounts and when it's
directed at something important are
really helpful they help us get things
done so once you decide what you really
want to work on what is that specific
concrete goal then we need a deadline in
my own life right now I'm creating
something new that I am so excited about
and I have dates in the books for a few
months ahead where we are shooting the
thing I'm working on so I've got a whole
crew coming and I know exactly what's
going to happen that's a deadline that's
very real I can't wiggle out of it you
know what else that does it helps me
keep things simple so when other people
are trying to tell me hey Marie I want
you to come do this or come do this
speaking engagement or what about this
particular project I'm like no hell to
the no you know why because I have this
clear specific important project that
has a deadline which gets me very
motivated to get things done
one of the biggest challenges that most
of us go through when we're starting to
explore spirituality and discovering the
whole idea of being super grateful for
what you have is we can feel guilty
about wanting more it's almost as if oh
I really have to just you know be okay
with everything I have now which is
great but it's human to want to create
it's human to want to grow to want to
explore to expand and take in more and I
just want to make a little note here you
know wanting more doesn't always equate
to materialism it doesn't always mean
toys you could want to touch more lives
you could want to expand your ability to
love so wanting more in and of itself is
nothing that you should shy away from
and I absolutely believe with my heart
and soul that you can be extremely
grateful for what you have and go balls
to the wall with your dreams so I have a
few strategies to share with you that
will help you accomplish this
in my lovely book called make every man
want you how to be so irresistible
you'll barely keep from dating yourself
which by the way we're going to give you
a free audio download Missy just because
you asked such a great question I talk
about a concept called this is it this
is it really means that you treat this
moment like it's the most amazing moment
of your life you look around in your
world and you just make it the best it
can possibly be so in short wherever
you're at that's where the party is so
if you find yourself standing in line at
a bank and there's a really long line
and everyone else is cranky this is it
this is your moment so you're gonna
party with it you're gonna hang out
you're gonna have a great time talk to
people on the line really appreciate
where you're at but that doesn't stop
you the whole this is it mentality
doesn't stop you from having Big Dreams
that you're also going to pursue so it's
a matter of just finding that balance
but you can absolutely do it and don't
let anyone tell you that uh you're
ungrateful for what you have if you have
big dreams and Ambitions so one more
little note and it's about complaining
this is a great way to just basically
check yourself before you wreck yourself
Chickity chickity check yourself before
you wreck yourself if you catch yourself
complaining you've slipped out of the
modality of being grateful for what you
have and it's going to be really hard to
really attract great things or be really
ambitious or have the energy you need to
achieve those big dreams so use
complaining as a bit of a barometer if
you find yourself then oh this sucks my
current client sucks my boyfriend sucks
not so good stop it don't beat yourself
up but just get back into the Grateful
mode and keep kicking ass towards your
dreams frame your dream and here's what
this means we can't become what we can't
Envision so when I say frame your dream
what I mean is I want you to take a
picture of it in your mind's eye in
Vivid specific detail and then what I
want you to do is translate that picture
into words meaning write down that big
unrealistic dream and I know that you
may have heard about the power of
writing things down before but the truth
is most people just don't do it which is
so crazy because the research is
conclusive on this there was a study
done by Dr Gail Matthews that shows that
you are 42 percent more likely to
achieve your goals if you write them
down so what I want you to do is whip
out your journal or hop on that keyboard
and get writing first things first if
you don't make the change right now
you're right you will will pass along
all that self-doubt to your kids if they
see you as someone who's not willing to
take risks as someone who's not going to
go for their dreams you're going to wind
up creating your own family of realist
and what I mean by that is people who
are unwilling to go for their dreams
unwilling to be unreasonable and here's
the thing Kristen as you know sometimes
the best things in life come when we're
being unreasonable on the other hand if
your kids see you taking action and
going after your dreams and being
willing to embarrass yourself every once
in a while they're gonna get the message
that it's safe for them to take risks
and to go after their dreams instead of
just dreaming about them here's the
other thing about what's missing from
your life Kristen what's missing is fun
just because you're in a slump it
doesn't mean that you've outgrown your
house or your marriage or a job all it
means is that you've outgrown your
tolerance for leading a boring ass life
we human beings need to be creative we
need the adventure and the excitement
and the variety that comes from creative
and Endeavors and when I was reading
your question that little line that you
have about dancing that you wish you
could dance you wish you could sing
tells me that you are creatively
malnourished you are starving right now
and look you don't have to go audition
for X Factor or do anything crazy like
that you can just start singing in your
shower if you want or you can take dance
breaks at the office I'll give you an
example for my own life I am a bit of a
closet hippie and in the past year I've
been starting to go to drumming circles
I have no idea what I'm doing but I love
it sure I could have let the fear of
looking stupid stop me but when does
that stop me before so many things in
life can feel urgent but they're not so
a few examples checking email answering
calls or texts even from clients and
social media
urgent things demand our attention now
and they can get really addictive
because we all want to feel wanted now
many of us also like a little hit of
drama and adrenaline which email male
and social and tax and things like that
happily deliver and finally things that
are Urgent often relate to other
people's goals not our own but important
things are different important things
are quiet there's no alarms there's no
drama important things often relate to
our own goals and dreams not other
people and unfortunately it requires us
to be self-starters and important things
are often easy to blow off hey Marie are
we still hanging out today or she's busy
sorry okay I'll hit you up tomorrow see
where you're at we'll see we'll see
about that
uh we have stuff to do
um the first order of business let's
check Twitter right yeah okay now Angela
I know you got clients to attend to and
work that pays the bills and sometimes
yes that is urgent however you do have
enough time to create your art and reach
your goals as long as you work on what's
important first and save what's urgent
for a little bit later here's how to do
this now before you get going each day I
want you to take a look at your to-do
list and you're going to Mark each task
with either an i or a u i is more
important and U is for Urgent and then
work on all the eye stuff first and save
the use stuff till later now you gotta
remember the Urgent stuff is always
going to get done because it has to but
this method ensures that your important
tasks don't fall to the Wayside and
unless somebody is seriously hurt or
your house is on fire if something
urgent tries to take your attention
ignore it until your important work is
done for the day I think that particular
story I was around like seven or eight
years old so I was a young child and it
was a little precocious thing to do so
at that age the only thing I could
potentially attribute it to and this is
you know pure speculation is a natural
knowing I think that Divine connection
that we all have to something greater
than ourselves
um I feel in many ways like part of my
life is to Simply Be A Channel and to
listen and then to speak and share and
so the confidence and certainty I also
want to say this I feel like I
oftentimes embody radically
um opposing things at the same time so
while a lot of people may watch our
videos or even read the book or see my
newsletters or or social and be like oh
my gosh she's so confident I need to be
real I'm also terribly filled with
self-doubt I am also a person that
questions myself I'm also a person that
sits back and goes like I don't know is
this any good like I don't think
so both
the coexist I think that once I've had a
chance to Grapple with something for a
little while and also like road test it
meaning I've had a chance to play with
people use Concepts in real life work
with them coach with them see how things
actually come out how it impacts them
and helps them create results then the
confidence builds quite naturally so
that happened for me when I started as a
coach again I knew internally this is
what I wanted to do but I was very aware
that I was like I don't know crap right
like I have to build up that track
record over time same thing with like a
program like b-school I am very
confident when we go into our we only
open it you know once a year when we go
into our promotional period I get really
fired up vision and it's not false
bravado it's because I'm like I'm
graduated 64 000 people and I've
literally been approached in grocery
stores from women who were on the verge
of homelessness who now run multiple
six-figure businesses and they tell me
like their children's education are
completely funded so when I get fired up
about anything like again about this
book I'm like no y'all I've Road tested
this please For the Love of All Things
holy just give it a try you don't have
to believe it try it before you deny it
though because this is good so I think
um any confidence that you detect one I
just want to underscore it was born from
terrible insecurity that I still carry
around with me now and a lot of
self-doubt anytime I'm starting
something new or I'm stretching into a
new Zone and then the confidence side
just comes from also I've been doing
this now for 20 years like starting in
1999 and it's now 2021. you just I think
that's one of the best things about
maturity and that's one of the best
things about age is like you're like
I've been around the block a few times
and I've seen a couple things and I've
fallen on my face so it's all gonna be
okay and I think probably one of the
other things again not to push it but
Vision I know you and I are both such
fans of books you know one of the by
products of adopting the belief that
everything is figureoutable is what I'd
like to call remarkable resilience
remarkable resilience and also a bit of
Courage because
this belief this notion that everything
is figureoutable is so a part of my
cellular DNA that I literally feel
Unstoppable not Unstoppable in the sense
that everything's gonna go my way
because it certainly does not and not
Unstoppable in the sense that I'm like
better than anybody else but Unstoppable
in this sense that if there is something
that I want to learn or experience or
achieve or help bring about I am 100
certain that if I'm committed to that we
will figure it out we will find a way or
we will make a way and when you have
that core belief embedded in you which
is what we teach you how to do in the
book it shifts everything because look
at how much our World Vision is filled
with uncertainty and filled with fear
and uncertainty that's natural right we
kind of kid ourselves into believing we
have some sense of control but when you
have this Bedrock belief that everything
is figure outable when you believe in
yourself that much all of a sudden
you're able to to stand in the tornado
of uncertainty because you know without
a shadow of a doubt that whatever comes
down the pike no matter how hard it gets
no matter how much you cry no matter how
much pain or suffering or confusion or
doubt there is you are going to rise and
you will make it through you know it
doesn't cost you anything not to believe
in yourself excuse me it costs you
nothing to believe in yourself but it
costs you everything not to there's a
prompt in here that I have used so many
times in my life and so many times in my
business that has transformed everything
in a business context it's led to like
multi-million ideas and in a life
context oh my goodness I can't even tell
you how many things it's helped me shift
and it all comes back to tapping into
that wisdom that I already have in my
heart that I wasn't really aware of so
what you're going to need is a journal
or just a notebook or a piece of paper
and I want you to give yourself at least
15 to 20 minutes of uninterrupted time
with no cell phones around no things
bringing or dinging no televisions no
nothing I just need you to put yourself
in a place where it can be kind of quiet
where you're really comfortable maybe
you have a little cup of tea or cup of
coffee or something stronger if that's
what you're into whatever floats your
boat and you're going to use this
sentence stem to start to unearth what
Ellen might really want to focus on in
this next chapter of her life so the
sentence stem goes like this wouldn't it
be cool if dot dot dot so I want you to
write down on a paper wouldn't it be
cool if and then whatever Springs up in
your mind in your heart I just want you
to write it down so wouldn't it be cool
if I lived in Hawaii wouldn't it be cool
if I could solve world hunger wouldn't
it be cool if I had platinum blonde hair
I don't know I'm just making stuff up
off the top of my head but what this
exercise does is it starts activating
your imagination it starts dusting off
that ability you have to dream that I
suspect may have been put on the back
burner for so many years because you've
been focused on so many other people
because you're so responsible and you're
so loving and you're such a good person
but now my friend Ellen now is the time
for you to ReDiscover what's in your
heart and what would really be cool for
you to focus on in this next chapter and
I promise you if you play with this
prompt wouldn't it be cool if and you
let yourself dream without editing
without squashing something down because
you feel like oh that's impossible that
could never happen no we don't do that
in brainstorming we let everything down
on the page I promise you you will start
to unearth something that's going to
make you go
that feels amazing could I really do
that could I really be that could I
really pursue that and you're gonna get
like little tinglies arms will stand
yeah the arm hair will stand up all that
kind of good stuff but it will only
happen if you give yourself this ability
to play with this prompt and do it until
you can't write anymore my question how
can I go about projecting myself as a
writer first and a teacher second what
business steps can I take to make this
transformation thank you for all you do
Christina all right so Christina we got
some good answers for you today there's
actually three very simple very
effective things that you can do right
now to make that transformation and make
it happen fast
the first one is speak it so words have
tremendous power all you got to do next
time you find yourself at a cocktail
party just say you're a writer first so
anytime you introduce yourself talk
about writing talk about your books talk
about everything else before you start
saying you're a teacher and that's going
to make a huge difference so um what we
like to say is just do it
just do it just do it Christina number
two number two you want to write it so
all language that goes out into the
world think about this what is your
email signature say what does your
business card say what about any social
media profiles the very first thing that
you should have is ding ding ding writer
so if you don't have writer as the first
thing listed on all of your written
paraphernalia go and make that change
right now I'll wait
foreign
do it did you just do it okay good
um number three and this is the most
important one of all is be it you have
to write as much as you can so if you
don't have a Blog I would highly suggest
you start blogging perhaps journaling
will be more your thing but just really
be the writer that you actually are and
it becomes pretty simple if you're doing
something habitually you're writing
every day you're putting out blog posts
you're publishing more books naturally
it's going to be the first thing that
pops out of your mouse when I was first
training in terms of wanting to be a
coach and becoming a coach it was so
much in terms of personal development
work and it was awesome I loved working
with clients I was like 23 24 years old
and Not only was I helping folks try and
get results in their own life I was also
doing this work on myself and one of the
things I realized was that defining
myself as a coach for straw that never
really quite felt right to me it felt
very limiting and narrow and not quite
on but I admitted that I had this dream
to dance now let's set some background
no Dance Training whatsoever never taken
a formal dance class in my life and it
was like I was around 24 25 which sadly
in the professional Dance World it's a
little over the hill to start right
that's a very very late start
and anyway I finally got real with
myself that I wanted to do this and so I
started taking professional dance
classes in New York City and it was
amazing I found myself coming alive and
coming alive and this was great and so I
I
um was taking class at Crunch fitness
and my teachers were like you're
actually really good and I remember Jay
I was literally like are you talking
about me I was like wait like I don't
have any technique they're like no no
you should really consider start
teaching and I was like yeah which given
the fact that previous to that I had you
know failed on Wall Street I had failed
in the magazine industry I had all these
failures and I was keeping myself alive
quite frankly because I wasn't earning a
lot of money as a coach by bartending
and waiting table so the fact that
someone thought I was good at something
was that just little grain of like oh
you are kind of good at something it was
great cut to I said all right I'm gonna
try out and become a substitute teacher
at crunch I'm going to teach these
hip-hop classes I had no idea what the
hell I was doing oh you're so cool so I
love that it was just sheer passion
right I was just doing everything I
could just trying to make it through one
of my first classes ever that I taught
on my own someone came up to me after
class and she said you're really good
and I was like thank you that means the
world to me she's like you know I work
for MTV and we're working on a new show
and we are looking for a choreographer
slash producer you should come in and
Jay it was a moment like this was my
first real class ever again so like
nervous and awkward and unsure of myself
so what came through my head you're not
ready yet um that it was like I was even
praying I was like Universe why did this
have to happen I am certainly not ready
I'm not good I don't know what the
hell's going on but this is amazing
opportunity because I grew up on MTV
yeah so I couldn't say no right because
again I could hear my inner clock going
like girl you're not getting any younger
so you might as well say yes so I said
yes to this opportunity and I remember
standing outside of the Viacom building
in New York City the day before I was
like when I was about to go up for this
interview that afternoon and Jay I
wanted to throw up like I was so
nauseous I was so not ready like I was
actually thinking should I throw up in
this like metal trash can or should I
like go inside and go to the bathroom so
then I can clean myself up before I
actually went to the interview
so I went to the building and I stood in
front of the boss's door the the person
who I was going to interview with and I
like shook myself out and I just said
you are not ready but you're going to
start before you're ready because it's
an incredible opportunity and no matter
what happens you're going to feel good
about yourself that you just went for it
and I went in for That interview and I
booked the job wow and so it was this
experience of me putting myself into
kind of this whole world that I was in
over my head so let's be clear I was
working with dancers that had decades
more experience than I did they were
talking about dance terms that not only
could I not perform I didn't even know
what the hell they were but I made my
way through by showing up as
professionally as I could by being
honest about my inexperience but also by
bringing my gifts that I did have to the
table and that one opportunity dancing
and choreographing and producing for MTV
that led to Fitness videos that led to
this Inc increased learning curve where
I got to learn basically three to four
years worth of experience in like three
months which eventually led to me
choreographing commercials for Reebok
and then eventually becoming um one of
the world's first Nike Elite Dance
athletes all because I was willing to
start before I was ready and every
single area of my life I still do in
business to this day there's so many
things I say yes to that I'm like
somewhere in the back of my mind is like
you're not ready yet and I'm like that
means I gotta go that means I gotta
strap myself in and go like we're doing
this I will learn as I go yeah so this
idea of starting before we're ready it
doesn't mean that we're irresponsible
doesn't mean that we don't do our
research and it doesn't mean that we
override our intuition that if perhaps
you know there was years ago and I'll
say this that people approach me to
write a book yes and I legitimately
wasn't ready yet but it was because my
focus was in other areas now I had other
priorities I knew from a deeper level it
wasn't about out the fear it was about
trusting my own timing yes but when you
know you want to do something and you're
clear that this is your path
using the Mantra start before you're
ready is an amazing way to beat
procrastination to LeapFrog over your
fear and to get going the average human
lifespan is absurdly insultingly brief
assuming you live to be about 80 you
have just over 4
000 weeks
oh I mean did that hit you in the gut
like it hit me
4 000 weeks I don't know about you but
to me that does not seem like a very
long time at all now assuming that the
vast majority of people watching the
show right now are like you meaning you
are not an infant that means you've
already blown through quite a big chunk
of your 4 000 week allotment that is a
sobering wake-up call am I right and you
know I think many of us have been
experiencing what I call the great
reassessment I mean we're still in this
Global pandemic right our entire lives
have been turned upside down and many of
us do not want to go back to the
Breakneck pace of the before times in
fact I think a lot of folks are
reassessing their lives and asking
themselves some very important questions
like how do I want to spend my time
differently moving forward I mean do I
really want to be on my phone for hours
a day looking at social media people
trying to convince you how great they
are do I really want to keep working
these punishing 10 to 12 hour days
staring at a computer screen as though
I'm going to get some Grand first prize
hustle trophy at the end or will I ever
get to rate that novel or learn that
language or take more trips or spend
more time with my family while they're
actually still alive I gotta say from my
perspective the great reassessment is
actually this magical window of
opportunity to make some long overdue
changes so with that in mind I'm really
curious where are you in terms of the
great reassessment has this been on your
mind lately and in your heart lately and
more specifically when you think about
this notion that on average in total you
get about 4 000 weeks to live and you've
likely already lived a significant
portion of that what specifically do you
want to do with the time you've got left
I mean are there some important dreams
and goals that you really want to
prioritize or are there some unhealthy
patterns and habits or even projects or
relationships that no longer deserve
your time or your energy now I don't
want you to just think about all this
right I don't want you to keep this in
your head I want you to actually write
your answers down in the comments below
because writing it down is a part of
what helps you make anything real
because guess what whether You've Got 2
000 or 200 weeks left I'm here to
challenge you to be courageous and
intentional about how you use that
remaining time so here is your
three-part question for this week
question number one
what's the one thing that you're doing
right now not because it's true to your
heart but because you feel it's expected
of you I mean maybe you're doing
something out of habit or obligation but
secretly you know that it's time to move
on so that's question number one
question number two is what's one
courageous change you want to make to be
more true to yourself in terms of how
you spend your time what's one change
that would make you feel great about how
you're using the remaining 2 000 or
however many weeks that you've got left
and then question number three is what's
one action step you can take right now
to start making that change happen so do
you need to make a phone call do you
need to have a conversation is it
something else like signing up for a
class or booking a trip doesn't matter
what it is but I want you to write it
down make it clear specific and
actionable I think all of us when we
love what we do and when we're
passionate about something we almost
have this sense of guilt about being
paid for it we shouldn't be paid for it
we can't ask for money oh I'll just do
it this one time oh I can't charge that
much I'm taking advantage of someone
else and so there's a lot of sometimes
subconscious sometimes just deeply
lodged beliefs about our own worth and
money and being paid for something that
we're really good at that is important
that we investigate that we Challenge
and that we choose our own beliefs
around money as money is this incredible
thing and a lot of women a lot of people
in general but especially women there's
a lot of conflict part of us wants more
and part of us feels guilty or greedy
for wanting it and like we're bad or
somehow that makes us I don't know less
spiritual less Soulful less authentic
and I think that's total BS I think
money is amazing it is the most
incredible tool that you can use not
only to take care of yourself and your
family but more importantly that you can
funnel to ideas and causes and real
problems in this world that take
resources to help fix and that's really
exciting to me and I think that the more
that women are financially empowered the
more everyone wins I mean the studies
have proven this time and time again
that when women get financially
empowered they take better care of their
families better care of their kids they
actually tend to have less kids
especially in the developing World
communities become stronger Nations
become stronger and really the whole
global economy is going to come stronger
so I get really fired up about women
owning what they're worth getting very
comfortable with money getting very
comfortable asking for it and also
becoming stewards of it meaning how are
they spending it on a day-to-day basis
are they feeling like you know what I
have enough right now to give to causes
I believe in I have enough right now to
invest in my own education my own
business my own future I think those are
really important issues and I think as
women we can't shy away from money we've
got to really dive into it and be
willing to swim around and investigate
all the places that we have screwed up
beliefs and that's okay all of us have
screwed up beliefs about something but
with money it's like we gotta get this
straight it's vital you had a quote
about this and you said beliefs are the
hidden scripts that run our lives and
that's one of those if you could get
people to really internalize the fact
that right now your whole life is being
dictated by the beliefs that you have
yes how do you help people unwind those
beliefs how do you help them replace
them with more powerful beliefs because
that is like a layer of the operating
system that is so wildly
underappreciated yeah that that's almost
always where I start with people yeah it
has to be I think for all of us I think
the first thing for us to go to is that
recognizing that beliefs are a choice
and every choice can be changed yes so
beliefs are a choice and every choice
can be changed do people react like
you're crazy when you say that
um you know I haven't floated that out
enough in a big enough audience to see
people like I don't believe it I'm dying
to know how people respond well let's
see because I I really think people
think that beliefs are recognition of
Truth and that to try to change your
beliefs is to try to deny the truth in
someone well I mean for anyone watching
whoever believed in Santa Claus
right like you believed things I'm
certain that I know I have like you
believed things when you were younger
even if you weren't a child if you were
a teenager or you were a young adult
that now
experience or wisdom or something has
shown you no that's not actually the
truth
anyway my point is this we collectively
have believed things both individually
and as a society over time that we've
changed our beliefs so I think that that
is proof positive that our beliefs are a
choice and those choices can indeed be
changed you know obviously there is the
phenomenon known as confirmation bias
which is the brain's um just it tends to
reinforce what we already believe and
then ignore information consciously or
subconsciously that doesn't match what
we already believe which is often why
whenever we're having conversations
about really um delicate topics like it
could be about gun control or
Reproductive Rights or race and they
just evolve so fast because people
hunker down in their belief bunkers and
they're unwilling to see another point
of view but I do hold fast to the fact
that all beliefs are a choice and
choices can be changed and here's what
else is cool
um you know this because you're so
immersed in the world of personal
development you're someone who is so
committed to learning and growth over
the years I've read more personal
development notebooks than you can like
just shake a tree at and oftentimes part
of the exercise is like you have to go
hunt down all of your limiting beliefs
right so if you want to become this
powerful person and be the best that you
can be you need to find every single
limiting belief and then change it and
do all these different things here's
what I realized when writing this book
you actually don't need to do that I
have a time saving tool because
everybody needs to save some time and to
make this really effective and efficient
if you adopt the belief that everything
is figureoutable and you take that on
for yourself you don't need to go
hunting down all your limiting beliefs
because that one thing is like the
master key that handles everything below
it it's almost like flipping a switch in
your Consciousness where then everything
else becomes possible so let's say if
you're like oh everything is figure
outable you bump bumped into something
in your relationship that feels like
it's problematic you're like oh I could
figure this out you don't need to go
necessarily looking for all those
limiting beliefs you may eventually
uncover them and that's cool you can
kind of clean them out but you don't
have to do all this front end work adopt
this one it's like the master key and
it'll help you achieve anything you want
for the rest of your life this is not
like hype I'm dead serious on this the
more you care about what other people
think the more they own you the more
power they have over you yeah and it's
like I want people to win that's who I
am as a person I want people to win I
want them to be well I want them to be
successful if there's anything that I
could possibly share that even a tiny
nugget of what I share helps them become
more of who they want to be then I feel
I have done my job successfully do I
have all the answers absolutely not no
way no one has all the answers but I do
believe that what we create in our
company and the programs we put together
and the things that we share help people
find their own answers so I don't
honestly I don't care yeah I really
don't care because if someone is
going to take the time to either make
that comment or that judgment it my
perspective would be that there's
something in their own life that's not
working that puts them in that position
of feeling a sense of pain or feeling
like they have to judge someone else to
justify what's happening in their own
life I just don't think that gets any of
us anywhere I think one of the biggest
ways that all of us can hold ourselves
back is listening to that nasty little
lie inside our head that says I'm not
ready yet I don't have enough experience
I don't have enough credentials who am I
to do X Y or Z and then we just delay
delay delay and before you know it
months if not years have gone by and we
haven't made any real progress you know
this was true for me you know when I
started my coaching career one of the
things I discovered was that I just
didn't want to be a coach I've never
really fit a traditional mode and from
doing all the personal development work
to train myself to be the best coach I
could be I realized I have other
passions I love spirituality I love
writing I love digital business which
was very new in the early 2000s and I
also love hip hop and dance yeah and so
so when I was prop 25 I finally gave
myself permission to go take my first
official dance class I never had an
official class as a kid I never took
ballet or did any of that stuff I just
moonwalked across my mom's floor right
and just loved hip-hop music but
starting in the dance world at 25 sounds
odd but you're kind of over the hill
yeah because most professional dancers
have been doing it since they popped out
of the womb right and by the time
they're 17 18 they're going on tour with
the hottest artist of the day
so the reason I'm telling the stories it
relates to start before you're ready so
I had finally gotten up the gumption to
go start taking classes my teachers told
me they're like you're pretty good you
should try and teach and by the way this
was in a gym environment so Crunch
Fitness in New York City that's where I
was taking classes because I could
afford it and uh I started becoming a
substitute hip-hop dance teacher and
again I didn't know what the hell I was
doing I just felt like I was out of
place but here's what happened that's
crazy one of my first dance classes that
I ever taught solo when I got done with
it this woman walked up to me and I was
still sweating I was trying to catch my
breath and she said you're really good I
was like thank you that's amazing she
said you know I work for MTV and we're
looking for a choreographer slash
producer I think you should come in and
meet my boss now Ed in that moment I was
so green in the dance world I didn't
know what the hell I was doing so my
brain was going I'm not ready for this
yes why couldn't this opportunity come
two or three or four years later when I
know what the hell I'm doing I'm better
prepared I could show up and maybe even
land this gig but here's what I realized
in my mind I was like you're already 25
which is over in the day over the hill
in the dance world and the only chance
you're ever going to have to see if this
could actually be a viable career for
you is if you do this so I remember
standing outside of the Viacom building
in New York City wanting to throw up in
the trash can because I was so nervous
because I didn't feel ready but I pushed
myself finally got up to that office I
knocked on the door I just did my best
in the meeting and you know what I got
the gig so cool and here's the thing
that one experience of being hired as a
choreographer slash producer by the way
I still didn't know what I was doing
when I was working with dancers that had
10 times more experience than I did I
was embarrassed because I didn't know
all the terms I didn't perform at my I
did the best I could do in that moment
but there were a lot of things that I
didn't know Maya naivete did show
however my growth and learning curve man
it skyrocketed and that one experience
changed the entire trajectory of my
career it led to me eventually becoming
a Nike Elite Dance athlete one of the
first in the world it led to Fitness
videos choreographing commercials for
Nike and Reebok and all of this stuff
that would have never happened if I
didn't start before I was ready I was
bartending at night waiting tables doing
assistant work like I was basically
working 24 7 you know in the evenings
and weekends it was all how can I just
make money to pay my rent and put food
on the table and in the days I was
really working my buns off trying to
create content create a newsletter get
coaching clients actually start working
with people and
um when I got engaged really young I was
about 23 years old and the guy was a
sweetheart but I realized pretty quickly
I didn't want to marry him this was not
the person I was meant to spend the rest
of my life with but we lived in this
tiny one-room studio in the West Village
and our money was already co-mingled and
so I was terrified because I felt like I
made this huge mistake here I am trying
to become a life coach and clearly I
have a lot to figure out about life I
knew I needed to get out of this
relationship but I didn't I didn't know
how to untangle what I had created this
big mess and so I knew once I broke off
that engagement I needed to actually
physically leave that environment that
was the only way I was going to get to
move on and so I called my parents New
Jersey and I said I hate to say this but
I have to move home I was so upset I
just felt like a total failure I felt
like a horrible person for breaking this
guy's heart and it was just it was a
mess like I just felt like such a
failure on every single level the fact
that I couldn't support myself yet the
fact that I had to go back to Jersey the
fact that I felt like I you know did a
number on this guy's life and um and was
really humbling but you know at the end
of that it made me realize I'm more
committed than ever to figure out what
it takes to make my life work and then
also to be able to share those lessons
with other people so hopefully they
didn't have to go through the mess that
I created if I could save people a
learning curve that was going to be
awesome and I think I was home maybe
like two or three months something like
that emotionally I had to heal and just
kind of get myself re-situated and you
know find a new living a place to live
in the city and get back on my feet but
it was probably one of the best things
that ever happened to me because it got
me regrounded in my own power and made
me realize that if everything falls
apart which it sometimes does there's
always a way to get back on your feet
the most accomplished and respected
people in the world stay humble they're
curious they're open-hearted they're
lifelong Learners don't ever feel like
you have to overcompensate for imposter
syndrome by becoming an arrogant had
know it all not only do you not have to
know it all but you become extra
trustworthy when you say these three
magic words I don't know
you know I consider myself a forever
student and I happily admit when I have
no idea what something is or how to do
something but you know what everything
is figure outable so not knowing doesn't
make me a fraud and it doesn't have to
make you one either what's the biggest
lesson you've learned in the last decade
for you
that things first of all keep getting
better I think in our society especially
as for at least to
um you know as you get older at least in
my family there was a lot of kind of
cultural expectations like oh over this
age it kind of starts going down or you
know what I mean you're kind of you Peak
when you're young and that's when all
the good stuff happens and for me I feel
like it keeps getting better and I love
that
the best years are still ahead of me and
that all the stuff that I've been
through there's like all of these
exciting new possibilities so that's one
of the biggest lessons and I think the
other one is that I don't have to stress
as hard like as a human being I have a
really strong work ethic but I also tend
to put a lot of pressure on myself and
the other lesson I've learned is that I
don't need to do that that the work
actually gets done more joyfully and
more creatively if I don't add on that
additional layer of pressure and stress
I'd love to hear about kind of being a
media maker and kind of a thought you
put into kind of the message you want to
show people yeah that's actually been a
really interesting Evolution because I
Am Naturally a super goofy person
um naturally sometimes an inappropriate
person there's things that pop out of my
mouth as being a person from Jersey that
other people will say you cannot say
that on stage you should not be talking
about that as a professional woman I'm
like but that's real and when I have
meetings with other people that aren't
on camera that there's no recording
device around that's actually how they
they talk to so why are we separating
ourselves to be like this very one type
of person when we feel like we're out in
public and then in private we act a
completely different way I just think
that's so hypocritical and so for me I
feel like also the the way that I best
express myself is when I'm not trying to
be anything other than who I actually am
and how I would talk to my friends you
know it's been interesting too with
marietv it's like I'm a woman who enjoys
clothes and I'm a woman who enjoys like
sometimes it's sassy and sexy clothing
and sometimes it's not sometimes it's
very
um you know there's boxy things that I
want to wear and sometimes it's really
casual and sometimes it's a little bit
more elegant but those are all sides of
me and so it's been interesting because
sometimes I'll put something on I'm like
there's a little too much skin am I
sending the wrong message to young women
but then I also have another voice in my
head that says but you know what I
actually like this dress and it makes me
feel good and I feel confident so I
think think it's it's something that I
don't feel like I have perfectly figured
out but it's certainly a conversation
that is very relevant it's very present
in my mind it's very present for our
team because what we want to do is
create media that first of all the
content is really impactful and second
of all that we're being true to who we
are and for me being true to who I am
and third of all giving young women a
different and diverse look at what it
means to be successful what it means to
be yourself and that you can show
different sides of you and be taken
seriously indecision is a dream killer
and the opposite what do we do about
that it's probably one of the things I
live my life by most besides the idea
that everything is figureoutable is that
Clarity comes from yes and I'll wait for
this yes we'll talk about that that
Clarity comes from engagement not
thought so one of the things that got me
off my ass right when I was thinking
about should I be a dancer could I be a
dancer am I too old to be a dancer oh I
think I am was just getting into that
friggin dance class that's what cracked
me open to a whole additional career
that by the way built the skill sets to
what I do today so my little kind of
offshoot my weird dancing thing got me
experience in front of the camera
teaching to Big groups leading music all
the stuff that we've talked about in
this entire interview built this
incredible skill set that now fuels the
brand that I have today that's
completely unique that would have been
if I just stayed narrow and focus on
life coaching I would have been you know
that girl with like an awful pink suit
and shoulder pads terrible
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one-on-one I did
with the amazing Marie forleo check it
out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there most of us exist in
this space of endless comparison the
compare and despair right so we have
either these idealized versions of
ourselves